hey this is the Society of the blind eye
didn't really learn anything in this one
I mean now mom okay yeah but you could
skip it so some of a dipper and Mabel
and Wendy and Sue's funding the club of
the Nome homos yeah weird um we
definitely thought that was Patrick
Stewart but it's not it's I think the
voice it's just the voice of Darth Maul
by just yeah in the Phantom Menace oh he
was the guy that voice - don't small
obviously uh
didn't do the stunts or anything but um
okay so a bunch of interesting stuff
obviously uh we're going start well the
funny thing you're right about the
mcgucket thing no no no but here's the
thing I forget I forgot the details of
this episode while saying like maybe
he's the authors of a libads like oh
yeah they clearly say he's not the oaf
so my buddy knows the Amidah yeah he
does know the author so um and pretty
much the setup is that they think he's
the author so they go to figure out what
his story is and they find the Society
of the blind eye who erases the memory
of people who see like supernatural
stuff kind of shocked favor come across
different may boy how do they skip that
um but nevertheless and maybe bitch is
not very good or they kept walking out
there on my who knows but uh so they
come across this and apparently this
founder was the one who put together but
they've erased their mind so much they
forget and when they finally um so they
have this great big fight and everything
and they erase their memories and they
have the memories of McGuffey and there
turns out he was this brilliant
scientist who I think I had to look back
but I think when he was looking at what
he knows about the journal you know like
there is a picture of a professor uh and
I thought it was the guy from that
you're guessing the next episode the one
Mark Hamill play but it's not it's
mccoggins so my bet they look at
somewhere uh you just know I like the
pass common people are like no it wasn't
bad it was this person so uh this is my
first time seeing it so yeah you you
you're fine you're I get worried about
my my memory I'm all those guys who like
is probably the gun used I'm a million
times because my memory is terrible
um but yeah but we do have and it's
revealed that he had this
he was the founder and that he had this
bro a mind he's been working with the
author but it's not actually the author
himself and he just got too addicted to
the Raygun and medium all crazy
forgotten now a human so I love the not
just the banjo
but the raccoon the stuffed raccoon and
then what was the oh uh dysentery yeah
right Harry dysentery mines me of Oregon
Trail I I sucked at that game cuz I
always died of dysentery buddy did that
like that was always the thing no but I
mean like I mean literally I'm like pack
for your adventure you're an
Independence Missouri pack for your
adventure and I'm buying supplies it's
like you've died of dysentery I'm like I
haven't even left yet so so the
briefcase computer laptop is is is
because his last name was like well was
it uh fiddle forward something like that
um actually that's what they said
Ford but yeah anywho um so he decides
he's gonna try and sort of get his
memory back and keep inventing stuff in
the sea what he can remember um and then
we have an ending with Stan once again
the machine that seems to be a portal it
seems to be like a Stargate is the big
thing cuz stuff goes in there I heard
his hand the prices I don't care how
long it takes it's gonna happen
my theory now cuz uh because it brings
up a Turing first yes uh because
mcgucket brings up also it was in 1982
and I think that's when the calendar was
and they kept saying thirty years ago uh
so again there's some sort of connection
there if I had to guess because he talks
about um you know like past girlfriends
stuff like that I had the calendar I
think there's even pictures of woman my
guess is that he lost somebody like in
that portal or whatever could be but a
1982 does keep getting brought up so
yeah it's definitely when all this
went down apparently yeah and thirty
years and all that stuff um so a couple
interesting things in the codes here I
can't I can't see which ones the ending
credits but one is if my suspicions are
correct this is the work of fiddle Ford
does he really have to go to such great
lengths to forget that was something
that according to this was the journal
three entry on the blind
died uh has this symbol that says that
so okay and nothing big but the
interesting thing when the last thing
that mcgucket says on the video before
it goes off he's like you know yeah I'm
a good kid now he makes a little
triangle with his head he says something
I think backwards um he's oh no no he's
speaking in at bash which transfers out
to bill cipher triangle so he knows
something about bill cipher he says I'm
sort of running with him which is
interesting and then the final line I
think this is the credits one yeah
ignorant is bliss but bliss is boring I
like that um so yeah a lot of
interesting sounds true a lot of
interesting stuff to take in the one if
Jason and Joey were here watches right
now I get a feeling uh there's something
very similar that happens in Adventure
Time with an old kook who's actually a
genius and I'm because obviously they
use a lot of the same people from
adventure time but it's a lot of the
same voice actors a very similar sense
of humor
I'm wondering if those either ascend up
or they had sort of the same idea at the
same time or something it's not an
unheard of trope either yeah I mean but
it's not quite to a point where it's
like ripoff familiar but it's like I was
watching it's like okay this is really
ringing some bells even down to watching
it on the TV
uh and it just looked very very similar
but um I think it's fine you know it's
still enough of its own thing and yeah I
really like how they took sort of this
side character it what you know who is
kind of like just a fine character in
the background made him like this really
big focus I'm wondering if that was
always planned I could actually see it
always being planned yeah I think
there's some sort of playing going on
here because he seems to have a concept
of where he's going with the mystery
like it seems some I don't know but but
you know you know how these things work
like we're happier here okay so we're
halfway through summer according to
season two which means like maybe he
planned this out as a three season show
that you know could be maybe it's like
avatar maybe it's got like a beginning
middle and end um so but yeah it's it's
a good episode regardless
of you know being very similar
adventuretime but I like giving this guy
a pass story I like you find out more
about the mystery I like the side story
with Mabel try and forget about boys is
ok but I think it was worth it just to
see Wendy make a beard hair just go to
stores the road I thought that was
pretty funny as a man I was very
offended by the way how dare you our
gender is not a joke um just fine but
it's not funny that's akin our dad took
me that both days over sensitive and not
sensitive enough that's the interesting
thing about it oh but no I thought that
was really funny uh and yeah just a lot
of cones lot of mystery in this one but
it still had a lot of really good laughs
and yeah I enjoyed it haven't you I
thought it was really good I don't have
much to talk about cuz I just keep
thinking of the damn mystery now yeah
you see like this one especially it's
like ya know you had an interesting
theory that was debunked I did but no
about you said well I gotta click me the
Arthur was good no no you say he could
be the author cuz he has the cast on his
hand maybe that's hiding oh yeah so that
was an interesting level and then you
see him with a cat yeah the old girl
coot I'm like well he said six fingers
and he has a cast on his hand maybe he
had one of the fingers chopped off or
something but now they seem to have
debunked it if look us later in the you
see him with five fingers early and then
later you see him like in a cast like
you know I saw a little that it was
disturbing her or something but it's
still like you do wonder how did he get
the cast though it's you see him in the
process I he gets it the arm race do you
know if the author's a man or a woman
have ever been gender specific like he
or she I don't believe so
what if it's grunkle Stan's wife or
lover or girl like cookie I am maybe she
was just born with a six finger or
something no no I have no idea what I
don't know I think they said though den
the shapeshifters say uh say it was a he
that six fingers but even then did did
he say he it's a shapeshifter who
believes those guys yeah but uh that
could be big I think we can trust mark
hamill yeah he's never played a villain
ever uh in the fight he's like the
world's most famous hero in all of film
and then after he plays nothing
bad guy yeah that's true oh my god I'm
Luke Skywalker and then he's like I got
a butch this up next thing you know
Joker and everyone iron are ya oh yes
sir two diabolical
uh was this a oh um swatch alert um the
dog stretching across this yeah this
week's show was brought to you by the
sweater weird stretchy dog 70s sweater
shirt thing maybe it's a dog
yeah um no yeah no I really enjoyed this
one I were marathoning these so this is
like episode 7 and probably I take a
break after this so I woke up at 5 in
the morning and I've been watching these
you know since 7 o'clock and it's we're
past noon now so I think I'm just
running my brains just shutting well I
think after this as of now when this has
come out there's only two episodes left
I will do the next two a couple days -
now before I leave for Christmas break
and then and I've only seen that I will
just have to do it yeah like whenever
it's released so yeah and I've only seen
of the next one uh after that I haven't
seen learn to love God or whatever it's
called
uh so yeah every episode after this
really will be like you know I like
seeing it for the first time I mean not
knowing anything what's gonna happen in
stuff so I'll be interesting but ya know
I this was a really really good episode
and then I am into the mystery I think
now that they're trying to solve or give
us some answers like cuz going into it I
didn't know what the mystery was I so
now it feels like it's coming together I
mean you've watched it once already so I
don't even know what to look for I like
because you're I watching it with him is
both fun demanding cuz he'll like he'll
have his a little like no thing here go
oh as I like scribble something down I'm
like what what did you see video oh so
you mean you didn't see that triangle I
did not do that I do not do that I tried
very hard not he actually twiddled his
goatee like I'm trying to pick you long
list with the top mama thorn but there
is a monocle of the book they'll say fur
has only what I'm Oh
yeah but he's always at home what what
are you looking at like there's just a
lot of stuff I never know I see your
funny jokes you know my memories so
terrible anyway I'll forget it so I have
to write at them oh no but yeah that
good episode I don't know what else to
say just interesting interesting very
interesting yeah who's the author well I
can't possibly solve this mystery can
you